Patt 40 Sports Illustrated senior writer
as we somehow make the smooth segue in
here good morning Pat how are you I'm
good I vote for Washington monuments
well yeah but we've been tearing down
monuments haven't we and you know yeah
yeah but actually make for an ugly
helmet to it just the Washington
Monument how was your week by the way
insane really I didn't expect it but
that's kind of how this whole thing is
gone it was really busy trying to keep
up with what the big 10 was doing the
pac-12 is doing the Ivy League was doing
you know things are happening it's and
it seems like the pace of the
deconstruction the season is
accelerating did the Ivy League wag the
wag the dog here maybe you know it's a
little different they certainly did last
march in basketball football is a little
different because football is such a
bigger revenue generator for the power
five and really the Oliv FPS versus
where the Ivy League plays it but they
set a tone of we're pulling back and I
think you were saw that some other
conferences were quick to follow that
obviously the big ten which a lot of
other conferences were surprised and a
little bit annoyed that they went that
quickly and basically unilaterally that
way and then the pac-12 goes to
conference only and I think the other
power five comes is probably will
eventually follow by the end of the
month
I'd explain this to me because your
lunch smarter about this than I am
Rutgers has out of conference games to
in New Jersey and one in Pennsylvania
against temple but they're gonna get rid
of those and let them fly across country
to Nebraska so explain that to me here
of the logic of the Big Ten well there's
the big logical hole in this now what
the Big Ten will say is the biggest
reason and they went to this conference
the only thing is that they can control
the whole schedule and basically spaced
out nine or ten games across thirteen
weeks because they feel like it's
inevitable that there's going to be some
weeks when you're gonna have you know X
number of positive cases of the virus
and not be able to play and
if it's with a league opponent they're
like okay we can just shift that around
and make this work okay
and I think that they just feel like
that so it's a lot more easy to maneuver
across the course of a schedule when you
take some weeks out of it and add some
open dates there the other thing to Dan
is that at least all the Big Ten teams
can say we're testing the same way we've
got the same protocols we're all gonna
decide on Thursday hey is your team well
enough to go play on Saturday you know
as opposed to when you're playing
Monmouth or temple you can't necessarily
say they're doing things the same way
yeah I didn't know if it was a another
way of delaying this season if we took
out those non-conference games that you
start the season with that you can buy
yourself a little bit of time and I
don't know if that's part of this as
well that maybe you start to leak into
October more than playing games in
September could be gonna be and we'll
find out because the Big Ten had does
have some early conference games
scheduled so we'll see I think they're
hoping to try to hammer out something of
a schedule here by the end of this week
that may be too soon but we may start
hearing some word whether that is the
plan whether just to push everything
back to October 1st I think they'd
probably rather go by mid-september at
least and like I said use some of those
weeks for cushion in case they have
cancellations or postponements during
the season how optimistic are you right
now that we have power five conference
football games not very not very I mean
it's it's been nothing but dwindling
confidence throughout July you know it's
funny the ebbs and flows of this thing
as we've talked about before where you
know late May
halfway into June people are really
bullish and we're gonna play and we're
gonna have at least 50% film capacity
stateís fans maybe even 100% and then a
month later now we're like boy I don't
know that we're gonna play you know
there's more and more people looking at
the spring I think as a possibility
although that has its own problems I
mean we could lose so many of the top
players then who just simply say I'm not
going to play but I'd say I feel less
than 50 percent sure that we will play
football in the fall I go back to what
Kirk Herbstreit said I think that was in
March
and remember everybody came out of the
woodwork and attacked him where he said
I'm paraphrasing that we might not have
college football he doesn't see it
happening and here we are right now and
what Herbie said back in March
unfortunately may come to fruition
absolutely you know this I mean really
you can kind of look at this whole thing
has just been this state of denial and
I've been part of it for Americans
probably in general but American sports
fans of like every time something's been
taken off the table like what really
there's no way no you know the Ivy
League they're not gonna play by their
basketball tournament that's crazy
I'm sure then we're not gonna play an NC
double-a tournament and then we're not
gonna have any spring sports and then
the Olympics get postponed and the
Masters and so on and so on and so on
and now I mean everybody was like surely
will still have football and I think the
people that looked at it you know the
pretty sober I back in the spring and
said we may not work were the ones that
were ahead of the game and I also wonder
we're talking to Pat forty from Sports
Illustrated I'm wondering about these
big-name players in college football
that are they going to play this season
would we hold it against them we you
know we have players who sit out a bowl
game but if you're Trevor Lawrence or
some of these other players I just
wonder the risk and the reward of
playing a season and do we have players
who opt out of the season because they
want to get ready for the 2021 draft you
know I mean but I think if you feel
pretty secure that you were going to be
a first or second-round draft pick
you're probably out other guys you know
we're maybe third through fifth round
picks you're like okay I want to try to
improve my status still so maybe I want
to play but I think there will be some
of them till say it's just not worth
getting injured I think it's gonna be a
really really difficult thing if it's a
spring season for schools to be able to
put you know anything close to a full
high-powered lineup on the field if you
are at a power five team with a bunch of
perot prospects it's gonna it's gonna be
a major attrition what's Notre Dame do
well that's a great question I wrote
about that way back in gosh was in April
or May I
but I talked to Jack Swarbrick then the
athletic director and he said he that
the the ACC Alliance basically would
help them in it has they've got six
games scheduled with ACC teams they
should play all of those job John
Swofford the Commissioner has said that
Navy absolutely wants to play them that
gets them to seven beyond that we'll see
you know I would imagine Western
Michigan is still out there saying yeah
man we're scheduled in there please let
us play let us go to Notre Dame Stadium
and play that game for the money and the
exposure so maybe that gets you to eight
and after that I don't know if it's a
spring season you may not get more than
eight maybe eight or nine games if I
made you the head of the NCAA Mark
Emmert
and he actually had power what would you
do
that's the thing you see this is lay
bare how little power they have over
anything you know but first of all what
I would do I would absolutely there will
be uniform testing and eligibility
procedures as far as whether when
players can practice when they could
play when teams could play secondly I
would have every conference commissioner
in Indianapolis I mean if the SEC could
kind of ATS could meet in person today
in Birmingham you could have everybody
in Indy and say we need a completely
uniform schedule here we need we don't
need this conference saying that and
this other comer is doing something
different we've got to have some sort of
unified schedule here that actually is
for the good of everyone as opposed to
every conference being out for
themselves
well we liken it to the five mob
families the the power five and then
there's no boss over those five Mafia
families that that's what you have here
it is that's where all of a sudden you
know Michael Corleone can go sit all
family business one day without
consulting the rest of them and that's
mayhem it really is I mean we'll see if
they actually come to some uniform
decision but there's absolutely no
unifying power involved here great talk
to you again Pat thank you my pleasure
Dan thank you that's Pat forty covers
college sports for Sports Illustrated
there senior writer